FINAL DECISION.
WE WILL BRING YOU ANY UPDATES AS
THEY COME.
NOW IT IS TIME FOR OUR "SEEN AND
UNSEEN" SEGMENT WILL BE EXPOSED
TO CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
TONIGHT, HOLIDAY YOU'VE PROBABLY
NEVER HEARD OF, A GRAMMY
SURPRISE, AND MORE.
JOINING US NOW, RAYMOND ARROYO,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLING
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK WHILE WILDER
AND THE AMULET OF POWER THAT THE
INGRAM CHILDREN ARE READING
BECAUSE I'M READING INTO THEM,
AVAILABLE AT BOOKSTORES STARTING
ON TUESDAY.
ALL RIGHT, RAYMOND.
TOMORROW IS VALENTINE'S DAY.
>> IT IS VALENTINE'S DAY.
>> Laura: BUT I GUESS I MISSED
MY OPPORTUNITY.
>> NOT YET.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY IT IS
GALENTINES D.A.
THE SO-CALLED HOLIDAY ENTERED
THE CULTURAL CONSCIOUSNESS IN
2010 WITH AN EPISODE OF PARKS
AND RECREATION'S BECOME A
PHENOMENON.
HERE'S THE EPISODE IN QUESTION
I'VE TELL YOU WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> WHAT IS GALENTINES DAY?
>> IT'S ONLY THE BEST DAY OF THE
YEAR.
EVERY FEBRUARY 13, MY LADY
FRIENDS AND I LEAVE OUR HUSBANDS
AND OUR BOYFRIENDS AT HOME AND
WE JUST COMING TO GET BREAKFAST
STYLE.
LADIES CELEBRATING LADIES.
>> LAURA FANS OF WOMEN ARE
FILLING RESTAURANTS AND
CELEBRATE EACH OTHER.
HALLMARK HAS 16 GALENTINES CARDS
AND OTHER CARDS, FEATURE
GREETINGS LIKE "YOU ARE A
GODDESS, GLORIOUS FEMALE
WARRIOR" OR "UTERUS IS BEFORE
DUDERUSES."
51% OF AMERICANS ARE CELEBRATING
VALENTINE'S DAY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE GREEN.
ST. VALENTINE, YOU WILL REMEMBER
WAS BEHEADED FOR ERRONEOUSLY
MARRYING COUPLES.
THE EMPEROR THOUGHT HE WANTED
THEM OUT LOUD.
HE WENT FORWARD WITH MARRIAGE.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR HEADS
OVER THE STEELY GALENTINES
THING.
I DON'T LIKE CH.
IT'S ANTIMALE BIAS IN GALENTINES
THAT I DON'T LIKE.
>> Laura: IT DOES SEEM A BIT
DEFENSIVE.
IT'S A DEFENSIVE HOLIDAY.
I'VE NEVER BEEN ONE TO SIT
AROUND WITH A BUNCH OF WOMEN OF
THE TABLE.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN MORE OF A
GUY'S --
[LAUGHS]
>> THE RESTAURANT WANTS A TABLE
FULL OF LADIES AND WOMEN LOVE
BUYING FLOWERS AND CANDLES.
MEN, NOT A BIG THING.
WE HAVE A VALENTINE TO SHARE.
>> Laura: IS YOURS FIRST?
YOURS FIRST?
>> YOU ARE THE RIGHT ANGLE FOR
ME.
>> Laura: REBECCA WOULD LOVE
IT.
IN GENERAL.
>> THERE'S ANOTHER ONE.
>> Laura: THIS WOULD BE FOR
RAYMOND.
ARROYO WANTS TO BE YOUR BOY-O.
YOU ARE FIRED, WHOEVER DID THAT.
[LAUGHS]
MICHELLE OBAMA.
MADE A SURPRISE AND VERY, VERY
GLAMOROUS APPEARANCE AT THE
GRAMMYS ON SUNDAY.
A NEW SERIES OF TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN HER MOTHER AND HER HAVE
BEEN RELEASED, AND IT IS A BIT
CURIOUS.
MOTHER ROBINSON, AS SHE IS
CALLED.
>> WE WILL PUT IT ON THE SCREEN.
MOTHER ROBINSON WRITES "I GUESS
YOU WERE A HIT AT THE GRAMMYS."
MICHELLE WRITES "I'M SITTING
HERE WITH VALERIE.
JARED I GUESS.
THIS TEXT IS SO TYPICALLY YOU.
DID YOU WATCH IT?
>> SHE SAYS SHE STOPPED BECAUSE
GRACIE CALLED ME.
DID YOU MEET ANY OF THE REAL
STARS WERE DID YOU JUST RUN
RIGHT AFTER YOU WERE DONE?
>> Laura: I TOLD HER EYE WAS
GOING TO BE ON IT.
>> NO, YOU DID NOT.
I WOULD'VE REMEMBER THAT EVEN
THOUGH I DON'T REMEMBER MUCH.
>> Laura: EMOJI, EMOJI, EMOJI
LAUGHING.
I THOUGHT I TOLD YOU AND I AM A
REAL STAR BY THE WAY.
I AM A REAL STAR BY THE WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SHE IS THE ONLY ONE WHO CAN
PUT MICHELLE IN HER PLACE, AND
SHE DID.
>> Laura: I LOVE MOTHER
ROBINSON.
>> LAST WEEK, YOUR MEMBER DAVE
FROM SASKATCHEWAN, FORBIDDEN
FROM PUTTING HIS NAME ON A
PERSONALIZED LICENSE PLATE.
THIS WEEK HE FOUND SOME
SELF-LOVE, HE GOT A DECAL OF HIS
NAME, "ASSMAN" ON THE REAR END
OF HIS PICKUP TRUCK FOR ALL THE
WORLD TO SEE.
>> Laura: IT'S PRONOUNCED
OS-MAN.
>> NO, IT ISN'T.
HE SAID IN INTERVIEWS ASSMAN.
DAVE ASSMAN.
HE'S PROUD TO BE A ASSMAN.
B BROWN.
IT'S VALENTINE'S DAY.
HE'S FINDING THE LOVE.
>> Laura: WE ARE NOT PLAYING
THE SEINFELD AGAIN.
>> NO, WE DID THAT LAST WEEK.
>> Laura: MOTHER ROBINSON USED
TO COLLEGE MY RADIO SHOW.
>> SHE DID.
>> Laura: AT LEAST SOMEONE
SAID SHE WAS MOTHER ROBINSON.
SHE SAID MR.
IT WAS ALWAYS A LITTLE FISHY.
>> RANDOM HOUSE SENT ME THIS.
I'M OPENING IT ON THE SHOW.
>> Laura: TALK ABOUT LIKE A
GRAMMY.
>> IT'S LIKE THE GRAMMYS.
THE WINNER IS...
>> Laura: DON'T YOU HATE THAT
PLASTIC BUBBLE WRAP?
>> YOU SHOULD HAVE THE PROPS.
DONE.
CAN I GET IT OPEN?
>> Laura: O.
>> MY FIRST HARDBACK, THEY SENT
IT.
SO EXCITED.
>> Laura: COMING OUT MONDAY?
>> TUESDAY.
THE WHOLE FAMILY CAN TAKE PART.